Pixar has officially sold out what's
next Wally on ice can someone please
send this nine hundred year-old
Gallifreyan to an interstellar DeVry
Institute where he can relearn the
fundamentals of galaxies saving a skimpy
169 minutes of running time devoted to
the entire first six chapters of the
book the trims are unforgivable Kirk and
Sulu fighting out a sky platform and
following hundreds of miles of the
planet's surface oh I will only see star
trek into darkness once during its
theatrical run at full price I mean I'll
go see it again on a matinee but I won't
pay full price more than once
subscribes the wire channel and never
miss one of my rants your move Jackson
you